Alors, qu'est-ce que Qiskit ?
Qiskit est un kit de développement logiciel open source
pour travailler avec des ordinateurs quantiques
au niveau des circuits,
des algorithmes et des modules d'application. Ce SDK
permet à tout le monde de programmer de vrais ordinateurs quantiques depuis
son ordinateur portable. En deux lignes de code, tu peux accéder
à plusieurs systèmes quantiques, allant des supraconducteurs
aux qubits à ions piégés. Tu veux émuler le comportement d'un ordinateur quantique ?
Change une seule ligne de code
et simule tes quantum circuits sur notre simulateur haute performance.
Qiskit est un outil utilisé par des dizaines de
milliers de personnes dans le monde entier, qui cherchent toutes à
construire l'avenir. Que tu sois chercheur, développeur
ou simplement en train de faire tes premiers pas,
Qiskit propose un certain nombre de
fonctionnalités adaptées à tes besoins,
permettant à chacun de faire des choses
comme créer ton premier quantum circuit,
exécuter des algorithmes quantiques interdisciplinaires
et étudier des phénomènes quantiques fondamentaux.
C'est peut-être le moment idéal pour t'impliquer toi-même
et trouver tous les outils dont tu as besoin,
notamment de vrais ordinateurs quantiques
et le SDK, via Qiskit,
ainsi qu'une communauté qui sera ravie de t'accueillir
et de répondre à toutes tes questions en chemin.
Tu peux commencer dès aujourd'hui
sur Qiskit.